all right our next speaker is she's
going to talk about minimizing training
okay thanks a lot for inviting me so I
was told that I'm supposed to bridge
discrete optimization and continuous
optimization right for this workshop and
and I'm not really working on discrete
optimization but this is why the
training Erin a you see they are really
discrete problems and it's just this is
kind of a case study what can we do
I'm not necessarily advocating that
that's what we should be doing with
these problems but but it's sort of
what's interesting to me at least I
don't know I'm hoping other people will
find it interesting so the training Erin
auc I'll talk about what it is I mean
obviously everybody knows training error
but you see not maybe everybody knows
but it's a it's a standard in the
industry to measure your classifier many
people treated this some kind of would
the thing that needs to be good right
needs to be close to one so we will but
it's actually a very simple you know
it's very simple mathematical expression
and can be therefore optimised okay so
the I'll talk about these two functions
they're both step functions where they
come from so the basic setting of
machine learning so you of course know
it but just to define a patient so we
have a simple set of training data
available data and we are going to so it
is distributed according I mean it has
some distribution which we don't know
and it's pulled out the the data is
pulled out as iad from this distribution
and then the goal is to find a predictor
which is good for this distribution
right so ultimately what we want to do
is we want to find a predictor and
usually we need to narrow down our class
of predictors to some particular class
parameterize by w right so this w and
linear predictors is you're just Linea W
the
you know didn't that defines the
hyperplane in neural networks it's all
the weights in all the neurons but
essentially this is the function that
you're trying to somehow measure its
quality in terms of predicting your
output Y and then you want to maximize
the probability of a good prediction and
this is deliberately left vague okay but
in case of so I'm going to talk about
binary classification exclusively so in
terms of binary in case of binary
classification it's a very specific
thing that you want to optimize you want
to optimize the probability that your
label and your predictor have the same
sign right so binary classification is
plus minus 1 the labels are plus minus 1
so you want to basically predict the
correct sign of the label and you
measure your accuracy as the expected
probability that you have a correct
prediction right this is what you want
to ultimately optimize and then of
course since you have a finite set and
you don't know your distribution you
don't know how to optimize this directly
show you what you do is you look at this
function right and this function is just
simple sample average approximation of
that through optimization problem except
for here I've switched to a minimum just
because it's kind of more familiar so
instead of maximizing the correct
prediction I'm trying to minimize the
number of wrong predictions right this
is the same thing and this is 0-1 loss
which is basically measured as 1
whenever my prediction is wrong ok so
this is when I first started here I'm
got machine learning problems everybody
says well this is great but this isn't a
hard problem because this is basically
the stepwise function but really it's
this is not even the function that we
want to optimize we want to optimize
this function it's not clear that what
does it mean np-hard anyway who wants a
solution of well yes I mean
well then Ben has this other definition
of f heart problems this is not this is
this this is a this problem it's in big
hard if you want to optimize this you
know exactly but who really wants to
optimize this exactly one optimize this
function right so this is what I'm kind
of will be talking about a little bit
just to you know again everybody knows
this but typically when people like in
machine learning course they say well
this is the hard problem to optimize
because it's non convex and whatever
we're gonna replace this loss with the
logistic loss and logistic loss has nice
properties then it does I mean there's
no question about it so it's nice and
convex if the if predictor is linear and
so on so this is what typically is
optimized but let's go back and look at
this function so I'm now going back to
optimize the accuracy because it's just
you know a little bit easier for me to
use notation so this is my function
right my function is the basically
indicator function that my output is has
a same sign as the label and then I
average them out and this is accuracy
for a given data set for a particular W
so my function would look like this
what's the problem with this function
the problem this okay I don't know if
exactly if it'll look like this but
it'll probably look something like this
this function has a fairly clearly
defined minimum and the problem is that
it just we can't compute the derivatives
rather we can but they're gonna be zero
everywhere right so this is this is the
biggest problem with this function it's
not np-hard it doesn't really matter
what mod matters is that derivatives
gives us zero information so it's an
interesting case like I've been working
on black box optimization right
derivative free optimization usually you
just say oh I don't have derivatives
here you have derivatives they're just
completely useless so can we do
something about this so clearly we are
hoping that the function that we
actually want to optimize look something
like this it may not be convex but it's
probably nice and it probably has some
kind of a decent minimum
and this is the this is the function and
expectation right so this is what we
actually want to optimize not this but
this right so we just don't know so this
is a surrogate for this function so
let's first think when I mean why do we
think the function is smooth well I
don't know it's smooth sometimes it's
not smooth some other times for sure did
this function but it depends on the
distribution but typically the only
distribution we can think of is this
normal distribution and for all no
distribution it turns out to be really
smooth and maybe this has been done
before I have we haven't found that with
my student in the literature it's it's
sort of a fairly simple analysis that if
you take basically two normal
distributions and you're trying to
separate them by linear so I'm fixing my
classifier class to the just linear
predictors so if I want to separate them
by linear classifier I can actually
write the expected accuracy as a
function of the moments of the W and the
moments of my distribution so let's see
I have a one normal distribution with
first and second order moment mu P and
Sigma P here's new and Sigma and is a
negative and positive class and then the
expected accuracy which is this function
of W is can be just written like this
where this is the just a typical
probability density function for normals
and the the arguments here are
essentially just the combinations of the
moments for the original distribution
and W so this is a smooth function of W
that's the bottom line okay it's a very
nice smooth function of W moreover you
can actually compute the gradients of
this function there's nothing blackbox
about it okay so it was kind of
interesting we just thought okay well
clearly this we don't first of all we
don't know the distribution is normal
and even if it is we don't know the
moment but let's just try it and see how
it works so so we've tried it what did
we do let me just go back we take
big dataset right we compute so if you
know the moments if we know it's for
sure we just plug it in and take this
function and optimize it with using
gradient information but if you don't
know the moments we just estimate them
from the distribution or even from the
sample set this is approximate so here
we tried it on artificial data a number
of samples is a thousand produced to
kind of nicely relatively separable
distributions then exact moments because
it's artificial data we know the moments
these are approximate moments and this
is what you do if you run logistic
regression on the same problem what you
get so what are we having here it's
basically the so these are different
dimensions and basically this is the
final accuracy that you obtain from your
linear separator from each of these
optimization runs okay so this is the
direct optimization this is the best you
can do
logistic regression doesn't do quite as
well which is you know should be the
case in principle and this is the
approximate moment case which does
actually quite well when the dimension
is relatively small and when dimension
gets larger it starts not doing so well
here and that's reasonable because my
number of samples is fixed so if I have
more samples I can you know improve the
quality of my estimates of the gradient
so here I'm computing gradients that are
inexact and not in a very clear way so
it's not like a stochastic gradient it's
some well yeah I'm not sure it's the
stochastic gradient I actually haven't
analyzed it but because I'm computing
these moments in some approximate way
and then I'm plugging into the gradient
I don't think it's going to be exactly
unbiased estimator is this stochastic
gradient but it's not necessarily
unbiased okay so the interesting thing
about this this is something that there
is no really once they estimated the
gradients once estimate the moments I
have direct formula for the gradients
there is nothing dependent on n here the
only thing that depends on end
the number of samples is outside the
optimization process so it's actually
very cheap I mean if dimensions it's not
very big this is a very cheap algorithm
and it runs faster than logistic
regression because logistic regression
needs to compute the access data every
time right so does it make any sense
does it work on in real life okay a real
life is the strong word here on small
subsets of a you see sorry you see I
data said so that's not definitely not
real life but so we tried it we thought
it's not gonna work at all because I
mean this is done the assumption that
distribution is normal but it actually
surprisingly works well and especially
look at this case we we got much better
accuracy than for example something can
be obtained in logistic regression in
this amount of time versus this amount
of time so it works sometimes it doesn't
work some other times here what happens
we were still going to you know explore
what's going on but essentially they the
way my student implemented this right
now is she's just doing line search with
the with the gradient step and of course
the gradients are basically it's a guess
whether the gradient is right or wrong
and right now if the gradient is wrong
and it happens to point uphill you just
get stuck you don't move anywhere so you
know some kind of maybe additional
Socastee City may help here but this is
where the case is where things get stuck
so we don't go to get good result but
who knows so it's it's I don't know I
found it fascinating it actually can
possibly work and yeah it's um so we'll
see where it goes but but I'm not
necessarily advocating these methods
it's just it sounds kind of as an
interesting possibility and then okay
let's talk about AUC which is very
similar really but you see is
that's where we started because it's
somehow unlike accuracy it is considered
even more sort of black box weird
function but essential is the same thing
so what is a UC accuracy is not always a
good measure so let's think of basically
and balance imbalance data sets where
you have so you're trying to predict
spam versus non spam email right so you
have 99% of spam email and 1% of non
spam in your email so if you label
everything as spam you have 99% accuracy
so you're great right but except for
it's obviously an awful classifier
because all your email goes to spam so
the measure of the classifier and for
the not for imbalance data sets is not
usually your accuracy but it's the
trade-off between positive false
positive rates and false negative rates
or true positive rates so what what
people sometimes do in is to find such a
classifier that has good a you see they
just way differently the positive and
negative class right so if your spam is
only 1% you just put a lot of weight on
incorrect classification of your
non-spam emails and you know you hope
for the best but it's not really
necessarily the best way again to deal
with things because then you need to
pick up these weights and then the
output depends on weights and sure
you're biasing yourself to specific
selection or weights and so you have to
then choose the weights that give you
the best AUC and people you know
sometimes do that so what is a you see
is like an industry's determined is
defined as the area under the ROC curve
there is a trade-off between the
positive false positive and true
positive rate so this is different I'm
not going to explain what it is if you
don't know it doesn't really matter
because on the next slide I'll explain
I'll show much better than much more
clear definition how do you compute that
you see but but the essential thing is
it's the area and their curve and the
curve if the curve looks more like the
blue one then the area is bigger and
it's closer to one so AUC
something that is between zero and one
and you want it to be as close to one as
possible
right but the the simple way to compute
it is the following so you take positive
and negative class let's say that they
distribute it according to some
distributions right you pull out your
data from those from positive and
negative and then instead of computing
the error of your predictor in the sense
that label times this predictor bigger
than zero you just count the number of
positive examples that are basically
being labeled higher than the negative
examples so you look at all the pair's
and for each pair you see if you have a
correct ranking right so this is also
known as the ranking loss so it's very
very similar to the accuracy except for
now you're just computing this error for
all the pole pairs and the kind of
important thing to note that computing
this function value you think should be
quadratic in terms of like let's say you
have well an unbalanced data set it's a
bit different but but let's say you have
n over 2 so and data total and roughly n
over 2 in each of the data sets then the
amount of work here is scaling is N
squared but except for it's not because
you can actually do this by first by
computing all of this for all the data
and then ordering the data and then it's
so it's n log n actually so it's it's
good you can do that with this loss but
if you replace this one here with
logistic loss you can no longer do that
so what if you replace this with
logistic regression kind of
approximation your every function
evaluation becomes quadratic in it so
it's but on the other hand if you
replace it with huge loss it is again n
log n so it's a 1 has to be a little bit
careful with this how do you treat this
a you see even though it also looks like
a 0 1 loss function ok
all right so back to the same thing we
don't want to optimize this we want to
optimize the expected loss and expected
loss
or expected AUC which is essentially the
probability that when you pull out two
points one positive one negative what is
the probability that your predictor is
going to rank the positive one higher
than the negative okay and again so is
this a smooth function I am really
curious because even probably from
geometrical perspective one can analyze
this for various sort of assumptions on
distributions but again we just did it
for normal distribution or jointly
normal in this case because you know
it's positive or negative classes here
you kind of need to you don't need to
but you can work with the jointly normal
distribution and then you again have
exact formulation for this probability
function and it again is just some
probability density function from normal
with a particular form of the moments
which are derived from the moments of
your distribution of your data okay and
again we can do the same thing in the in
terms of we produce random datasets that
are artificial coming from normal and we
compare it this time not with logistic
regression but with hinge and then we
can see how well we're doing and you
know of course here we do better than
here but CDF so with the approximate
moments we don't do quite as well we
still do reasonably well the official
data just validating that we do things
correctly and then we are we did this on
the real datasets as well and again it's
surprisingly kind of works it's not not
always working great here we didn't get
kind of stuck but but on real data sets
we managed to get some optimization
again the left column is a lot cheaper
to compute because it's completely
independent on the number of data
well you compute the moments and then
you run your optimization whereas here
you have to do this n log n steps every
time if you want to access the
data okay yep you're calling out the
ones where you're doing poor okay right
yeah right right there are something
pretty much so I would I probably would
have done it if I had really something
that it really beats this is the
annoying thing so so far the only thing
I can show is that we we I mean we do it
faster and we can do as well right
that's that's the only thing right we're
somehow not managing to get better
result but maybe it's not not surprising
after all and and these are these are
this UCI data says that that are overfed
by so many algorithms right so it's kind
of hard to get an improvement on them
anyway okay so now next like okay this
works sometimes it doesn't work
sometimes great
maybe we can improve it maybe we cannot
but what should we do in general should
we use the gradient estimates yeah maybe
but on the other hand these so this
gradient estimates that I was suggesting
assume that distribution is normal but
the function estimates that I can
compute from you know just the computing
a you see they are their true estimates
they're unbiased estimates of the true
expected value function that I'm trying
to optimize so I can actually optimize
these functions directly just using
function values I can't use the maybe
the gradients if the gradients are
incorrect but the function values are
useful for me so here I can indeed use
something that does not use derivatives
and this is what you know what we did
and I'll show you some computational
examples and then I'll go into theory
why are we thinking that this is
reasonable and the thing the reason we
say it's reasonable because we can
basically assuming that the underlying
function is smooth and I showed you that
the underlying function is something
particular in the normal
tribution but the smoothness is a much
broader class this so much broader class
of data will give a smooth expected
value functions and if they are assuming
that this is smooth and we can estimate
the function you know to some accuracy
we can run methods that converge and
this is what I'll talk about in this
kind of the end of the talk so the
current problem with using these methods
I'm just saying upfront is that the
derivative free methods don't scale as
well as the gradient based methods with
W and that's very possibly going to
change because there hasn't been
actually worked and trying to scale up
these methods until recently but I think
Jorge is going to talk about this and
you know there's a lot of interest in
scaling up these methods and this is one
example for example why we maybe should
why they may work well but another
alternative this is just so if we can't
scale so here we're saying that we
cannot scale with the dimension W so
maybe another alternative is just to
reduce the amount of variables that you
are optimizing over and that's actually
well known as hyper parameter tuning I'm
not going to go into details of that but
hyper parameter tuning essentially does
this it just selects few parameters then
run some kind of a method that computes
the eventual W for example logistic
regression that depends on some
parameters and then computes a you see
on top of from this W that being
computed by some other method and then
goes and optimizes the resulting
function the AUC function right my point
here is that the hyper parameter tuning
has been used recently quite you know
quite a lot and there's a lot of papers
on that but again under some conditions
the underlying function will be smooth
and then you can actually have some
guarantees about the methods convergence
and convergence rates and things like
that for that case even though yeah you
see looks like a very strange and black
box function okay
all right so just a few I mean I have
maybe some too much of computational
results here but what I'm just trying to
show I mean this is basically the bottom
line so we tried the trust region
derivative free method which I'll talk
about in a minute and we'll tried it on
various again datasets here the same
thing and basically compared to the
standard AUC and again sorry the the
optimization of a you see in the
standard kind of hinge approximation and
again we get about the same answer so we
don't really get something much better
usually or better at all as a matter of
fact unfortunately but we usually get it
faster with fewer functional relations
because you kind of directly optimize
the true function that you're trying to
optimize okay here is a larger data set
and then here's a comparison actually
it's a natural thing what we did with
the larger data set is that we try to
optimize it with the this assumption
that it's normal and using the gradients
right so we got somewhere which was not
so great this is the kind of the best
thing you see we're trying to get this
is what we get with just running
derivative free so it's clearly better
because you know the gradients are
really not correct so they're not
telling you the truth but the function
values are much more correct so we get
and this is just warm starting so you
can use the initial incorrect gradients
to run your method for a while and won't
stop start the derivative tree method so
we did that and it yeah it works
reasonably well here for example didn't
made an improvement with a warm starting
okay oh right what else did I want to
say we compared our method to
Bayesian optimization because Bayesian
optimization is very big for you know
derivative free optimization machine
learning community
and again results are similar but the
the methods they're talking about that
much much faster than Bayesian
optimization because Bayesian
optimization is a global method and it
really works very slowly we compare to a
random search that Ben likes and of
course random search really starts doing
very poorly when the dimension grows a
little bit bigger and you know here
we're hoping to kind of grow the
dimension to some reasonable size so you
know if we get better results and random
search for sure
this is hyper parameter tuning for some
particular case against based on
optimization the blue line is ours we do
well way to find okay so right so now
why are we justified in doing what we do
everybody can throw in some you know
random methods right and show plots and
say that we're doing well but this is
basically kind of why we we started to
been doing this so let's say we have the
following situation so now we have a
function which is stochastic we can't
compute the exact function right and we
may or may not compute the gradients so
this may or may not be available this is
always available some estimates of the
function and we may or may not have
estimates of the Hessian in again in
this case it depends how we compute them
right
so we assume so the the typical methods
that are being used today assume this
they assume that whatever you have the
stochastic estimate of the gradient
function value and the Hessian they're
unbiased we don't assume that but they
need to be sufficiently accurate somehow
and I will explain in what sense okay
and I think this applies here because in
this complicated functions that are
based on you know they did what I was
just showing you it they don't
necessarily give you an unbiased
estimate of the gradient but they
probably give you something reasonably
accurate alright so what we used is a
trust region method this is a
deterministic trust region I'll explain
how it extends to stochastic and not
lionsearch for sorry not well not
lionsearch not not the yeah for a simple
reason
well two reasons one is you we want to
use second-order information and we're
targeting non convex problems right so
we will be using second-order
information whether we are building it
from the gradients or from something
else usually from functions but we can
put in a hessian estimate here and it
does not have to be positive definite
and if it's not positive definite you
cannot use newton method directly you
have to use something like well you can
use cubic realization we're using
specifically trust region method and
they there's also a reason that at least
in our analysis currently it's essential
that we're using trust region method
because the transfusion step size does
not allow you to do crazy things
you update the trust region in a
conservative way slowly and it really
kind of makes sure that everything works
so it stabilizes the method okay what is
a trust region method so you you have
some kind of a quadratic estimate of
your function right so we're talking
there was a discussion yesterday that
mutant method is nothing else but
second-order Taylor series expansion so
exactly that's how we think of these
functions they're sort of like Taylor
series
pensions except for they're not
necessarily they may come from something
else but there is some quadratic
estimate which hopefully is like Taylor
series expansion you minimize this model
in the trust region so this is two norm
here right so again the first talk
yesterday was about using infinity norm
that's a very interesting application
here but if you have a non-convex
problem it's usually hard to solve the
subproblems so you can solve the sub
problem with the two norm specifically
and then we compute the improvement in
the function and improvement in the
functions like lionsearch is telling you
basically whether you should accept this
step or not this is a typical thing
right so for those of you who are not
very familiar with trust region methods
here's the kind of a picture
gray is my true function and the blue is
sort of this Taylor like model and here
indeed it behaves kind of nicely I can
minimize it and find a minimizer of this
model and check if the function and
prove that this new point and if it did
I'll move there and I'll make a step and
I'll construct a new trust region and
the new model and I'll continue doing
this but this is something that will
never happen with the Newton method
because this is completely wrong model
right this does not this is not a Taylor
model and the whole point is that we may
have something like this it's because
we're not requiring necessarily models
to be Taylor model and but if it doesn't
happen very often then it's okay so this
is where the kind of deep random
estimates come in once in a while they
can be really bad okay so for
deterministic case the theory basically
is roughly like this for the trust
region method so if this is my model and
this is so we call them fully linear
models or fully quadratic models to
distinguish that they're kind of like
Taylor but not quite so what what does
it mean
Taylor model up to first order it means
that if my displacement
is of the order of Delta from the
current where the current center of you
know where I'm expanding my model right
this is my displacement then the the
function value changes as the size of
this displacement squared right this is
typical Taylor model requirement for the
first order approximation and then this
is basically the same for the gradient
now the until our model again the
gradient will be exact but from this you
basically get to this now this is
essentially the behavior that you need
from Taylor like model well rather yeah
this is and the gray just the hessian
just needs to be finite this this is
nothing but saying that the hessian
estimation is a finite is bounded
there's no accuracy here it's just some
constant anything and this concept can
be anything just fixed okay so if you
get this then you have a first-order
convergence of a trust region method and
the convergence rate to the place where
your gradient is below epsilon is one
over epsilon squared which is the
standard convergence rate of stochastic
sorry of gradient descent or any other
first-order method if you have a second
order approximation then the rate of
convergence to a second-order stationary
point so that's the local minimum right
that we kind of maybe care about more is
going to be basically so the reach the
place where the second-order
stationarity is below epsilon it's going
to be 1 over epsilon cube again this is
standard ok so basically what happens
now we have a stochastic method which
works like this so it's the same thing
it's the same trust region method here
the model is assumed to be random okay
so all these quantities can be random
you again go and minimize this model
with respect to the trust region and I
just want to point out that this is
important that if for example I do
want to minimize my model exactly there
recently methods in fortress regions a
problem that are randomized and give you
some kind of approximate solution to
this a problem with some probability you
can actually view it as having around
the model and optimizing it exactly
right you can kind of reverse engineer
so this hides here the randomness here
actually hides a lot of stuff of like
using randomized linear algebra to solve
your subproblems which is something that
would be very useful to maybe implement
in derivative ascetic for example where
things are need to scale better or not
just in derivative free setting okay so
you have run the model and then you also
have don't have the function estimates
that are exact so you have some kind of
approximate function estimates but you
still do this and this is a guess
basically this tells me I am guessing if
I'm a function at improved I don't
really know because it's not a true
function it's an approximate function
but if this function is accurate enough
with a probability I'll be fine
and then there's an additional you know
condition that basically requires the
trust region and the and the estimated
gradient to be of the same side and this
is essential for convergence but it's
not really I mean it's a technical
detail in some sense but it's really
essential for otherwise the methods
don't work
okay so we have convergence results and
convergence rates and I just want to
emphasize what does mean convergence
rates because these days with stochastic
methods the convergence rates are very
different depending on what kind of
methods are used and what they really
mean because it's convergence rates and
expectation what does it really mean so
in our case it means a very specific
thing so to get to the place where
gradient is epsilon takes random amount
of time obviously we don't know when we
get there and it's a stopping time of a
stochastic process because your
algorithm when everything stochastic is
a stochastic process but at some point
something happens and it's a stopping
time and then you can analyze the
stopping time and this is what we bound
the expected stopping time this is very
different from say
the convergence rates of stochastic
gradient descent they're different but
the essential point is that we can get
the convergence rates that are very
similar to deterministic methods okay
and so these are basically the results
and the results are very very similar to
the deterministic case so if you have
again the first order method the first
order models so again we have to satisfy
these properties but now only with some
probability okay so this is basically
what will kind of happen if I estimate
my function values from you know samples
right and they don't get always good
estimates but I expect to get good
estimates with some probability then
then I have the convergence rate sorry
there should be one over epsilon squared
is the same as before and if I have a
second-order method so I have
sufficiently accurate Hessian estimates
so my this is kind of second order
tailor model but there's also an
additional assumption which
unfortunately had to be introduced which
again is kind of like second-order
Taylor approximation then again if this
happens with high probability then we
have second-order convergence
convergence to a second-order stationary
point with this rate okay right so this
is basically just tells you that we have
a generic conditions on your passion'
gradient function value everything what
does this really mean if we want to do
just estimate things by sampling so
Jorge will talk about that as well I
think a lot more but it essentially just
tells you how much you need to sample in
every iteration and it really depends on
the size of your gradient oh sorry oh
you a trust region so you're currently
at some iteration you have a size of the
trust region you you know how far you're
gonna go and you're going to basically
know how big your sample size has to be
in order to achieve a
proprietary with sufficient probability
so this is for first-order convergence
and this is for second-order conversion
so your function values have to be
accurate much more accurate than you say
your Hessian estimates because that's
you know that's what the theory tells us
and these look horrendous because of
course the trust region to the six one
over that so if trust region is zero
point one this is one over millions it
looks like really a lot well with a
cloud through in some sense and also
with a deep learning actually this is
not something I was talking about here
but with deep learning it may be
actually completely affordable to
compute the function value much more
accurately but the Hessian computations
with all the Hessian free methods for
example they did you need 30-40 whatever
conjugate gradient steps you may
actually save a lot by having a cheap
cheaper estimates of the Hessians but
that's kind of a sad thing however the
point is that we've tried for example
optimizing a you see with just sampling
data in a dynamic way but not at the
rate of 1 over Delta to the fourth or
not 1 over even Delta squared but
actually at the rate of 1 over Delta
simply so just slowly freezing the the
step size so it's not what theory tells
us but we're still not step size sorry
the sample size according to the size of
the trust region and here you can see
that this is basically so this is the
stochastic which one a stochastic
stochastics are here these are
deterministic so for example this is the
deterministic case is a stochastic case
does not get quite to the same accuracy
because I think we didn't get quite
sufficient number of samples in the end
but it does pretty well in 25 passes
through the data instead of 110 here in
40 instead of 250 so basically it it
does kind of work and then you know to
make it practical as a whole other
basically thing so what are the
conclusions I don't really know in that
sense we
just exploring these ideas so maybe we
should focus more on trying to
approximate the gradients of these
functions it might be interesting or
maybe we should instead focusing more on
scaling derivative free methods they'll
be useful in other cases anyway and then
you know analyzing the cases when the
these sort of step functions actually
are smooth and expectation and we can
guarantee convergence and convergence
rates okay you were showing this example
like this example by dimensional
reduction on UCI data you could get
better performance and boo this seems
like the main the main bottlenecks well
it's just because we're only generated a
thousand samples for 200 dimensional
problem so yeah I mean I don't know it's
okay right so so this is a cool yeah
this is the whole question that I don't
know a good answer to I mean some how
can we apply dimensionality reduction to
UCI datasets to actually get better
performance of the algorithm where we
use probability density functions but
with estimated moments so very possibly
or can we somehow yeah can what can be
done with the data to make it look more
like normal right yeah exactly I mean
very possible no idea any suggestions
would be great
I don't know we haven't looked into it
yet sorry like this is this was
literally I realized that I need to
connect with integer what discrete
optimization I'm gonna be like let's do
this let's try to run it and we ran it
so yeah yes I mean it's all open so far
so far we've been we have been
optimizing these functions with
derivative free stuff but I just wanted
to see what happens if we actually use
the gradients and to our surprise it
worked in many cases so yeah I mean it's
all a question yeah yeah so so I don't I
don't think we tried all varieties but
we haven't tried this for logistic
regression because I don't know if
there's I mean maybe there's a point
maybe there's a point I don't know it's
just logistic regression solving a
different problem but but yeah I mean
maybe I I'm just not sure why it would
necessarily help but but maybe it would
because then you'll still have
dependence on n in eventual iterations
right in the logistic regression and if
you use the Casta gradient and warm
starting it may not help so much but but
yeah with derivative free we definitely
did this and derivative he has similar
problems in some sense that it also
tapers off in terms of improvement so
this whole warm starting is not like a
perfect idea yet at least it's not clear
how much it helps but it's if it's non
convex problem it should lead you to
some maybe better local basin but yeah I
don't know
[Applause]